women surfers have been marketed very
sexually you'd see a girl in a string
bikini or a g-string standing on a beach
but when we go out there it's totally
different we're wearing full suits and
hoods and booties and we're not trying
to be sexy we're going out there to
become stronger better more awesome
humans
big way of surfing is really ferocious
people have said that women can't surf
it
but i do
i'm bianca valenti and i'm a
professional big wave surfer in san
francisco california
11 years ago is when i first served in
san francisco i nearly drowned and that
was when i decided i wanted to put in
the time in and out of the water and
start training to prepare and ride big
waves
[Music]
the water in san francisco is really
really cold sometimes there's even ice
on the sand in the morning and when it's
super cold your hands are tingly you
have to have a really thick skin and you
have to be very driven determined and
motivated because
this is in hawaii
mavericks is a surf spot where gigantic
waves break
it's been called the mount everest of
surfing
and it is located 20 minutes south of
san francisco
[Music]
an average sized wave is three to four
feet maverick starts breaking at fifteen
feet and there's been waves written in
there up to a hundred feet
people have died surfing mavericks it is
serious business it's for experts only
there's excitement there's fear
adrenaline
nervousness
happiness
it's really every emotion at once
when i hear somebody say that women are
not strong enough or good enough to surf
big lamps i just start laughing because
it makes me feel alive and i love it
it's about challenging yourself it's
about persevering and and
overcoming obstacles and so it's a much
deeper experience for me personally and
that's why i embrace
surfing in san francisco
[Music]
you